wearing over 300 pounds worth of
Prosthetics was so disorienting it gave
him vertigo Brendan Fraser's
transformation in the whale was
absolutely Standing Ovation worthy so
you heard right Brendan Fraser's
Prosthetics weighed up to 330 pounds it
was appropriately heavy and if you're
wondering whether that helped or hurt
his performance according to him I grew
to appreciate how strong physically and
emotionally a person of that size has to
be hey it's cool that he was able to
gain A New Perspective but strength was
far from the only problem Brendan had
with the Prosthetics not only were they
heavy but ridiculously hot too they had
to cool him down somehow so Brendan's
suit was filled with a series of tubes
pumping water through them you can think
of something sort of like what race car
drivers wear it took like a NASCAR pit
crew to create Charlie and that wasn't
even enough actually there were times on
set where the heat would get to be so
brutal for Brendan that a crew member
would have to run out to buy big bags of
ice to cool him down Brendan joked that
he went through eight bags of ice a day
so did you know that Sadie sink had
never watched a Brendan brazer movie
before she was cast this character that
he plays is very specific and I thought
it would be cool to kind of just see him
as that so the reason they were so
believable playing dad and daughter on
screen is probably because they became
that kind of close in real life too I
had a front row seat to watch this young
woman come of age and for what it's
worth Sadie's seen a few of his movies
since meeting him I liked School Ties
School Ties okay but Sadie wasn't the
only one who hasn't seen Brendan's work
Darren Aronofsky had never even seen
George of the Jungle or Encino Man but
after a long 10-year search for the
perfect leading man he'd pretty much
considered well everyone Brendan just
had such Star Quality about him and he's
really the kindest man on the planet
when Brendan found out that Hong Chow
had been hesitant to audition because
she had recently given birth Brendan
surprised her with a teddy bear gift bag
we named him Brendan Fraser bear that
was my daughter's first little stuffed
animal like how cute is that but going
back to the prosthetics for a second
they were designed in a way unlike any
fat suit for a movie has been before he
created
um Charlie in a 3D computer model using
an iPad the film's producer performed a
scan of Brendan from his own garage
which allowed Prosthetics artist Adrian
Moreau to build a clay mold of Brendan's
body and from there Adrian designed the
Prosthetics digitally before printing
them out in 3D and he did this all
without ever meeting Brendan so
designing the Prosthetics this way gave
Adrian a ton of Freedom when it came to
details like that beard for one thing
which was actually made by gluing each
individual hair down before being shaved
away to create the impression of actual
growth Brendan was such a huge fan of
the suit's level of detail he thought it
should be in some bougie Art Museum like
the Tate it was that striking to behold
Brendan was feeling like he was working
hard and getting nowhere about a month
into filming so for this one scene where
his character needed to apologize for
past mistakes it seemed like no matter
how hard Brendan tried he just couldn't
seem to get it right Darren Aronofsky
had to call for a five-minute break
after only one take and he called for
lunch after the second but to be fair
we'd be exhausted going through this
wouldn't you Brendan was seriously
hurting and had to step back to just
keep himself together and focus on the
job but Brendan wasn't the only one you
might see getting emotional on set Sadie
sync was incredibly protective over her
character and even rushing to her
defense whenever Darren Aronofsky would
call Ellie Neen so Sadie would admit to
you that there was definitely some real
darkness in her but she'd also be quick
to point out how that Darkness came from
this great deal of pain that she's in
now whenever you see books on a movie
set they usually aren't real books
instead what directors will do is rent a
whole bunch of prop books to be used but
in this case Darren wasn't working with
that kind of budget that would allow him
to fill an English teacher's library
with rented books luckily enough it was
the set dresser to the rescue she
brought in like a whole bunch of her own
books from home so Charlie's library was
actually stocked with several pieces of
classical literature now have you
noticed anything strange about the
layout of Charlie's living room couches
are usually placed up against a wall or
something but Darren Aronofsky had a
very good reason for placing Charlie's
in the exact center of the room this
allowed him to make Charlie the literal
Center of every scene or as he put it
he's kind of the son of the movie and
everyone else is kind of a little Moon
so do you think the cast and crew went
far enough when it came to humanizing
Charlie our little son at the center of
the story we would love to hear your
thoughts so make them heard in the
comment section down below